The joe rogan experience.
Um,
how much did you pay attention to Mckenna's theory?
Uh,
about,
uh,
the evolution of the human brain,
of the stoned ape theory that I looked at it.
Um,
but I,
I found I didn't find it persuasive and in fact if you press Terence Mckenna,
he didn't find an entirely persuasive,
it's a very,
it's an interesting speculation.
It's kind of a mind game.
I don't see how I can see how,
uh,
psychedelics would influence the mind and,
and,
and create new ideas,
new memes and Mike contribute to language.
But how does it get into the genes?
That's what I,
I the genes,
the genes.
Cause he said it changed us at the genetic level.
I see.
Psychedelics is having had a profound effect at the level of cultural evolution
that there are lots of interesting innovations that people who had psychedelic
experience introduced to our culture.
We talked about religion earlier.
That could be one.
A,
I had a wonderful interview with Stewart brand,
the founder of the whole earth catalog and his insight.
He had this profound insight during a psychedelic trip on the roof of his house.
In North beach and he saw the curvature of the earth in a way he hadn't before.
And he said,
God,
if we could have a phone,
this is 1966 we had never seen a picture of the earth from space yet.
And he said,
if we had a picture of the earth from space,
and we could see it as this round space ship,
that would change everything.
Because if you think of the earth is flat,
as most of us instinctively do,
it's endless.
There's endless resources.
Uh,
you don't have to worry about limits in any way.
But if we had that image and he realized,
I have to start a campaign to get NASA to turn the cameras around,
they're on their way to the moon.
Show us the earth from space.
And he said,
I,
I'm going to make a campaign.
I know.
And he's,
you know,
this is not an LSD.
I'll make a button.
Very important medium in 1966 I'll make a button and what should the button say?
It should be a little paranoid to get people's attention.
Why haven't they shown us an image of the earth from space.
Yeah.
That's what he would do.
And he started a campaign.
He started selling these buttons and the campaign got in the newspapers and it
goes viral as you know,
as viral as you could get in 1966 and two years later and NASA produce that
image and he put it on the whole earth catalog and that image galvanize the
environmental movement.
So it's those kind of memes that psychedelics introduces into culture and that
changes culture,
that image changed culture.
Um,
and I think there are hundreds of them.
I mean,
Steve Jobs talked about his use of LSD is very important to his,
uh,
formative experience.
And in fact,
there's a whole tradition of computer engineers going back to the 50s using LSD
that I wrote about in the book.
So,
but I don't see how we were selected genetically because of the,
there was an advantage to the people who were taking a lot of psychedelics.
Um,
that's where he lives at me.
Maybe I'm misrepresenting it.
His theory is that it coincides with climate change and these uh,
lower hominids experiencing experimenting
with different food sources.
So as the rain forest receded into grasslands,
they started experimenting by flipping over cow patties and finding grubs and
perhaps even mushrooms that were growing on these cow patties.
And his theory was that there's a bunch of different benefits,
one low doses of silicide but have been shown to increased visual acuity which
make it the hunting dogs in certain cultures.
Yes.
Yeah.
Make you a better hunter,
make you more in tune with what you're doing,
um,
that it would make you more,
it would a central nervous system arousal including sexual arousal,
make you more horny,
which would make you productive,
appropriate more often.
And that the,
the very unusual effect that psilocybin has on the mind could have led to
language and could have also led to the expansion of neurons,
the Dutch language to me,
Brainard of cultural evolution.
Sure.
Yeah.
The doubling of the human brain size though,
was it?
The particular thing is that it coincided,
according to the Mckenna,
it's been there.
There's a lot of people that disagree with him,
but his brother makes a very compelling case for him.
His brother Dennis,
who is still alive and it's brilliant,
brilliant guy.
He talked about it on this podcast.
He talked about his take on the stone or a stoned ape theory scientifically,
why he believes it's really what happened,
but that it does coincide with the change in climate of these,
these,
you know,
eight black people trying out different things and that the doubling of the
human brain size over a period of 2 million years is like one of the greatest
mysteries in the entire fossil record.
Their alternative theories,
I mean,
I wrote it all coincide.
Maybe cooking with fire.
Yes,
you can explain the increase in the brain size because you get more nutritional
value from cooked food,
the throwing arm,
the,
the desire to hunt all these different animals and the calculating all these
different ways to do that.
And communication.
I think there's cooperation.
A bunch of coinciding fat and it may well be that,
that,
uh,
people were eating everything right?
Our ancestors,
it's amazing what they ate.
And,
uh,
and no doubt they ate psychedelic mushrooms and no doubt.
I mean,
he also believed that language was a form of synesthesia.
You know,
in the way that synesthesia you can smell a musical note or something like that,
that you're taking a sound,
a meaningless sound,
uh,
you know,
um,
and,
and you're attaching it to a concept that maybe that happened on a suicide been,
but at a bunch of ideas that never panned out.
He was,
he was,
he was in audibly creative person and yeah.
And,
uh,
and they're all,
you know,
really interesting to think about some of the,
I think you could probably discredit based on what we understand about genes and
evolution,
but others are just really provocative.
That's where his brother comes in.
This is brothers and sisters to scientists,
strict scientists and doesn't,
he doesn't tolerate any of the woo and straight and he's skeptical of some of
his brother's ideas to open.
Yeah.
I mean loved his brother,
but he was like,
oh,
how a lot of things that weren't really accurate,
but also Terence Mckenna to would say,
well,
you know,
I'm just putting these ideas out there.
The guy was a constant pot user.
He was constantly doing psychedelics and really good talker.
He would have a podcast now,
right?
Oh,
it would be amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
I promote the shit out.
I would too.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was a fun guy to listen to.
You talk and there's a,
there's a podcast called the psychedelic salon that my friend Lorenzo hosts that
has pretty much every Terence Mckenna lecture and speeches ever done available
for free.
You can download it.
And Lorenzo is taking these and digitally remastered them.
So the sound is better and it's really awesome that,
that,
that he's got this resource.
But the idea that these,
uh,
lower hominids experienced ancient hominids experienced,
experimented rather with silicide,
but then this was what advanced culture or advanced language advanced their
understanding of each other.
It's a very,
very compelling idea.
Yeah,
it is.
And I think,
I mean,
the way I think about drugs like second,
Alex in evolution in the same way,
like in genetic evolution,
radiation causes mutations and some of those mutations turned out to be really
valuable.
You know,
purely by accident.
Some great new trait is introduced to the species and it increases fitness and
that person or that individual lives on in the cultural realm,
psychedelics are like radiation there mutagens they create change variation and
that advanced is cultural evolution.
Um,
all that variation,
all those wild ideas,
99% of them are stupid and useless.
I'll bet.
But that 1% can change the world.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Okay.